welcome to the obelisk summit between
teams
Venus price and everything
[Applause]
lewis takes crisis of the sector of
national systems human rights you are
went the witch and the world was unpublished
no 6 spirits and the one beaten
winners web of gamespy oven see a
concert
[Music]
to success
sp
in fact
and yes stocked tennis gorging me
canadian mourad under way into euros
a beast
m bye bye the ball as summer
mourad bilek richman of the property sold
so far a lot of experience
but audi prize winner dr donis curly
here we are comforted having blessed yes
Yes
victrix victims of sexual van moock vega
advanced expert and weng mok guy
and hold to the sick to youcef saïbi
thinks it's possible to lend fifty
we park at racing ford price minus
just like m
to seize the cd rom and security
the diplomat
[Music]
ferry
vc st michel
king
[Music]
dennebroeucq m
[Applause]
[Music]
who then quinn sonia chrome prince
no hitch princess put on then
like a wild rice safety committee
is the best
do not spoil people between windsor at
the welcome back and fair play balbronn
whitney lisbon por stanisic had beautiful
abandoned baby by lexus rebels committee
of the viajura touitou bathe the sophro
nobel committee thank you knew nobel
committee members and dying and hospital
novelli but neither walloon pipeau jump
indoor
[Music]
the company by global committee with the
wind sonia and the safety committee of
French troops
[Music]
faster my way
and
Oh
we
m
[Music]
and
we
I
[Music]
and
a speech down here as here of perez a
young yo majesty
your highness no peace prize lorieux
excellence is distinguished crate
ladies and gentleman of our origins our
beautiful alptis committee haided very world
of nobel peace prize food wine tasting
all given this weekend to nadia mourad
faithful and fuck the end of the use of
sexual weill in asia watten in the village
a man like cop say like a dragon
maybe i'm down in flames eight months
with iphone os x files
or we accept bundles in any and all
or offer systematic rake at this brunch
with militarist map gim works in cop
you hesitate work cry 2 responsible for
your eyes most people there and hate you
need is you enjoy
most end 10 and shangai boss massages
big slice loritz just united fights
soul
despite the very different by klaus
dennis nick clegg and me thurman alcan
belize nordia mourad and ye yang buman
here names of the ess eve related to
one and had just the watch or the head
are true little bit and victorious of
bring to mind the world's at 8pm
spices price laureate tawakkol karman
are coming
chris pryce or on breaking nice 3 go to
women's rights project
is against one person in just do it
against all mankind chi and madeline
arabian buman invoke to leave wade by
women in mail dominated societies
describe the fight for the dignity
right woman hamel like j dedicated their
world tour to the ears but to locate me
to check yourself at the bowling alley 6.2 me said
and things to all
women to vima already long champions
human dignity karim of the work of tara
korman peace prize and is dream home
ending at the next the gaza dreamcast in
say ok ok if you have a strong dare
buy in students this neat jump
daqui ears beautiful bright sky
lights hugh laurie hudson tate bags
at 200 is a new version of the universe
have stated to human rights document
tick the trays of the mobile to born
free and i could dignity and rights
'best section' is also a buzz to
is fundamental rights upright and weight
and democratic republic of congo
since ninety nine eleven to scor the live
six thousand Congolese son yann danis nick
clegg on my father jean dreuil number of
women ben jerry's cause like a
rottweiler jazz soul from all signs of
the conflict with leaflets young women
the referees act of dreams the cockpit
children brent and in the name
ending way the details
Inuit communities steelhead bros
securail the victim a woman born at 9:10
intervenes while better does not
standing money was being waits paris by
mostly worried apps simply can not
small experience sells continuously life
has defect to dr denys millet and women
victims ipad is right to 2 to
however provide treatment and programs
in the great women in the society at 0
but we are in 2009 and denial
shopping list of advanced studies women
business magazine forbes at beckett
will cause a mythical place noted yves
michaud has been the time of the world
the views you request
a clock malta of the victims saffron
end
hence a ciste to perpetrate the host country
like thibaut dennis microgard has made
in her straw in a ponytail she
been victim this side event of adventures
of fate and loves so many lives of making
sense in twenty two of one of his
bodyguard was killed in tac toe
meeting the affable guys and frau some
cause funding people at the mines is
clearly hear ball of health nih
smic them again we thank you
saffron
for women and against sexual health
Yes
[Applause]
and we are part of
speak about dennis loop rule
he
vi institute for the sound of you know dia
mourad kriouache has become
jihad coach and good life with love
woman li jinming lightman eagle one had to
hide his jump to make has a clause at
intuitive web site fourtine houses launch the
six games control and then i
work and he exterminated were acidic and
minority nadia my runs to 1.6 mode
Russian web browser weekend
ian whitman hangl sp is a partner of
british airways dam world title
insurance co both located at
mossoul from be used as aix lez hitschmann
pause
worse, you are an object
tumble on all models of news
discord should i give and well as gift
dreaming my man down is destroyed and burned
and meetings with the breaking total
like click the altimeters cow boys
extermination to the truth is the pipe
asaïs wishes domain to tibi clint
dempsey damaged the tvq
sochaux out of the most effective way of
the strain and community and by rail and
beyond like prime date extermination
van snick street with my paths had
always cities games in david jose
canes and waltz live by religious li na
dia mourad and victim of work rhymes and
has experience brutality muse of the
most horrifying kind send
autobiography jia describe the shock
kane daughter anne sense of the basement has
time she wants to give up small
f1 and net keys
ab the title resists musina the high
marne jean you are skate alger doses
and mitsou and brad pitt mourning
she is believing the nobel peace prize
for ever activities saab squint you want
time in hate captivity jia define
the good old games and size
day to speak up and wear up and rise
against his life and style with biocides
and women and children in doing so
has broken steegmans
the taz is cop 2 million we are
beamon deadly sexual victims is going
islands js dedicated the life of bering
witness to work premium
a making show that the world
never get this guardian brad we thank you
for you extra ordinary and orange
Yes
[Applause]
ladies and gentleman buzz dennis mme
claudia
contributed to combating vista work
rhymes iphone pool and tennis muzza
fring inflicted on women in evokes the
democratic republic of the congo
everyone else in the world we thank you
my love is used as we go
aware of dreams if we are bad boys ii
men in one time
Divine
[Music]
nba jam da viken special one va
complicate medicine in rabat bangoura sow
a cure and sexual sexual list like
he must be treated
longbridge of what we did
net collateral damage in the village
[Applause]
ladies and gentlemen or we say standing
of the petitclerc and valves turn back
way to women in bod has ever been in
to the problems of stability and true
and better drug status of night in night
lights and league b 6 faults international
criminal court you defined sochi act
would be a sexuality at work rise
wendy's act km / h board of systematic
attack and civilian healthy population
principles and clyde not well trained
says benoît ramdane djamel you win
can initiate systematic study
bright eyes of wight is wight spread
attacks against the views of the united
nations security underwear followed by
to get on the game surkin twenty five
peace and security and hiatus
house safe in one
resolution eighteen twenty from two
thousand ford stable at 6 miles and sing
and women in power and conflict
would you be international peace and
security is it
this little
a novel god you are you books at the price
lady of the thrush miss is important
oignies 16 justice everyone is business
dennis mark regan nadia morogues abos
made significant is killed in front of
process paul abine yves bolduc music
hate the scale of the hotel
demons prosecution the responsible
raves of the baye fall funky
inhale freedom band swing work is
in fact and contributed to the 100 m in 10
dry on valence and 1 between old boys
watten the can not be accepted mbow
offered primary as studio
however is it worked alfred nobel as
franck you do not you there is
get your man so fring in bouhriz
universo dave prentis out that women of
freedom and play in visible victims of
the happy at the word break loriette av du
world is from tadine justice and worse
combative we just s works rhymes our
country to our responsibilities
international livestock community problem
alsace would make this ring of alfred nobel
peace prize
leasings shenkman 10th world obligate
tennis nick clegg anadia mourad you
continue you go there you work little world
obligation to stones side by side with
in the struggle to end the world
times x files to fake kaldjob news
messages from two autobiographies
from when like stuff you gayda wimax
mike and young women
girls place generation all that
from sex from barbarism of
sexual work round 5
[Applause]
[Music]
lindsay price venus dennis showed
years of love to messi
[Applause]
if the track from the single container
a year
nadéah mourad or give her nobel speech
tyco times nadia mourad this stage formula
1 official gilbert ngoulakia
[Applause]
knew you're here it's slowly
maliki on his ride to dael the tunnels
motion it is idrissa of the workers
multinational choplin locals at the
radio
the street richard vadim anja thieme taken
by said jay z pma mass addictomac l
sink ramallah why harmony the word style
just clever tordjman mossad a leader in
fine if wayne swan lake louise harel
said aaron heilman fitoussi helium to
golden eggs was only the navy its mine
pale life tramps like aragon kaifeng
massira wyatt cat and the match of
diplomatic malaysia tahrir is it will be
brady vivadent at the crif awa the adage ndao
john michael mann konate layrac italy
serbia nor his voice pasta the rice john watt
and a half mazara all love the ipad to
lyon kingdom through business valley idaho
lyon but there a loam girl laura
the cats and lyon but las ventas heroes
daughter aline sagna at the trap
we are there and dignity sarah girl
admitted to the hospital al lawati hanna mina
the opera d'amorties quebec and joe rise
malagnou mathy helium vidaillac jadida
end but recognize there
yes sir alain bichsel dubai world
include a total stop jedid
the images upgrades look fans for
the paillade one to open the hacienda she
actually jean 6h any politics after
poroi then period coach profit from
high number of sinjar lemieux claudia
maarifa rence and simon rogers and novell
Islam the makoun man to the average
anis raache walcott to the notice of all
did the monaco lyon the maquina to
man an elevation of omnio status
takpara case of adjarra a fisherman from
barbie he goes calculating makes you smile
as for hlm become a life
of ascetic and hanoi rocks and mail to
google
agnès varda d'oeil to her long but
capitalia thomas one aicha belco bah
minera identifies sinjar the quina delmas
Batavian imac with malam state carbo
marconato their share to guillaume to
bad dairies in canada joly said li
bad for cats where it's me or even that everything
finished shokai you will do everything bann h
meal he was born to make the live shot there
and zi he arras hamlet mattress or
aguero béchard said savard said li bat
nam
then any interest of ben ali
women thannois I am who binds to
linen sabers get dressed fn ne
will sink he studied to hit anbar of
Rabat
kai financial and you get married
matches in my tommaso console that
did the match of michael cammalleri and
Wahhabi Islam is rising again
against the dollar at granby roanne took the
late litterna llc and iron mines alpha
mena imaginary but it increases
belonged to diana to work and attijari
razily bada the best Turkish profit
theatrical evening and mine to help them
to my daughter this high place to be
ducks of elise eddine chaouli romania
9 1 million same from my bled rumst to
force or help them or a scarf to
Mill pea nine massive series at 2.8
to nakiska bear head of age of the majorat
say well saved and fast from asbestos to
final ouaka art or alpha venezuela
palliative so here he reminded me
do not remember fachos material costs a
traveled during that year there the
fimat a challenge of tinder ali then a
age armin booth or way will you have
says iba from petain work for mac everything to
did the idea ya loud to djalal abad is
in particular to carmen of naira man has the
luna
oh yeah we are late by the gives
to chahbounia uchiyama that the whole army
suddenly his head died in belgrade
facing the leaders at the height at the way
we were marc alyn ware been redone and
the dominant radishes have to say it said
imam aulaqi does not deliver john terry bar
is forbidden double final to sezanne this
runaway at the elysée dinamia tahar
rayane john son of age mid-autumn
claude finally dumont diet hat
lemieux timbi does not have a problem with maraboutage
adlane the crumb masseube is dead and
kébé hadjar aïn allah said does not have any
so-called free fat and ethan the redoubt to
radfan actors instead of radish holly
hunter 2 m to dilate end there will bring back
the law hall and a skull and the
tinder match ali jawad imputable says
mrs. saada leader said li bad oeynhausen
nani made them and dig in manhattan
where he would remain martinez at the end
manual machata mara parallel flank
match started from walle and put the
frimas edits and y's and watatatow
thomas moutame midi the climate is mild to
read brains nakayama now so fun and
arabic he arrives at offers to hoymille
Maggiani Arabi in common and the match
tadpole ali is cassava or not even
actor holzman then offers you must
leave the jo where she wants it or
laity and vinasse baroda ali said
ivan to lyon
let's see the johnny layre harper
let your clique stop there
everything was destroyed jo abidjan and this
new islam ben gourion melodies
nataf a girl
minnesota wild card he will have paid min
nbim of rare archived itunes to the
rebellion
another girl he is so bad at
back to back marcato ita ni to bethanie
namco has the right to turn off the engine
truck man testimonials that are now
of july mobile weather widget at this
Huge manna and godmother of facv
where she went to dinara to bokassa to
bolidage men will yield them to
the request manade will thread ya
balcony in monaco makran de dravo as
kabylie girl lara my age bd ago
cunha of nouari of a well been
able eddine yahia moussa man then tahrir
the terrorist threat and al jamil
macaronade lara is a sedan in anata
crocodile having him kai feng is intimate
Montmagny at madoff carrie at
malaysia has just reaffirmed the henry
battle of fallujah and add that
brady djoliba from bamako did
the economy said itself tele nome as
interpreter owes to datong khalifa
the a310 ended only at the family at he
said because it's okay to go to l'albera
actually jean simon ammann at chinatown
miami aliot of male rats beauty
and nasa the ira mass finish the summer
to the easyjet mini phallic symbol
match between Copts and Ndinga was
admirable zoom has fallen to delight
local artists shahd jamil ahmad al
aoula al fatat may doan tran sympathy
of the Nafti champagne rally in China and
to those who sits at narrabeen deputy
except that no mode of famine is
arrived then that lyon to this marasmus to
zawiyah thomas and leila it was necessary to go
the real is a friend in the hospital and then that
lyon marseille claude fahd son then
beautiful smile williams lived men
yesterday she had him downplay everything or at
the iphone flocking to the pm3 finger the
Lorraine will hope the massonne haendel
country
for aude henneville will make niagara
karim saada tons of cassava said
gérard basset what has always
the dune a nomadic baseball terminal
quebec john heilemann funci of half that
wears
photo jd edwards is one of their
comrades at the party man so foot at
takoradi lebanon of Cotonou with two
comrades then arrive at the slab and s
dress up the white star people and white
hart lane martha the film like a ridge
nara from a small crash to landing at
his life has not laid them off from bahrain
and las palmas at this sentence she has it
says nature to dominate the one does jean so
it is the hall of iraty kabbage rhein of
dany saval faded h at local young at
the airport told green which
will remember and they will be welcomed jalil
al youm country of lanark alain mathot
did not know how to attack al haddad
I was so low
ring water areas
[Applause]
the on monaco was clean
I know life does not have too much to
mobilize our formats of the icon on
try to leave there monaco and giles
testosterone size of the naiad said
adrian nastase will criticize sabrine the
automotive therapies muttahida liman to
rouïba of jimmy howard is dead and that
ben ali baddou husband mujika marie chantal
Taïba de Moussa Mara Terminal Mine
bassano at her match ahmed wali
lamiaux mr. margot boer said iba
lighthouses pat bell face the hazard of lann
bihoué vélib such projects the portico
will host and mill in dallas we are in
some fashionable apple classmates terminal
will have to oil to the guitar of which he was
victim it is difficult democrat helmut
ahmad shah massoud was tinder match
ali welmant assisted from ahly germany
the different masters to the sick portel
fall will have this enemy its final actually
jean six movies in nadal and is
today quite rare at the time no
discharge pipe charpin then
month starts with alice salam del
rises to marca net of lacrosse nba light
the emirate of ras al amud where the loopholes
like ibod as kalou has tons he
should be crowd
besides, the wali bad at the waist must
NASA will have this year the same sculpin
betar illit nano caral nadine monetary
to come said liberatorial road the
Courneuve alone made of arms is liman
adults and wetteren sai we have some
shots at the current minister mash up final
that gives cayenne mbaye diouf
who shoots jurors capitals at hadal
awatib is a plague of tears in val-de-ruz
gilad baden baden jaw too
rischmann omstar and tombs the mark
opens the mark in any case to say
helium with tomato terrible fruits here
makoun not to doha at the end of the round h
in total the mark quickly to wafer
ode to the road and calls himself liberal and
that apple did johnny da takapuna wrong to
give the mines the mine will land the
radar of tears
[Applause]
italy in total indoor assassin's
creed entertainment comrades go up to
2 she said thomas beatie samro salon
it's him because the nine Maori heads to
heed the notes favorable to
the estadio el hammam and room at same
watson ouattara exchanges terminal
macaroons but the news that I see
not he made wade young intercommunal
mara and my style of criminals
machacka wade will do what
Pierre Amélie and Benares Medal
banal match comrades but sao tomé
sharka telmarins jan kounen to dakar and
the banal jewelery match na radio 1 a
traveled eddine so must we moment
sabers their pactole state of march
of amarna maracana radidi nra today
to the patient at the ica finally a black year
stand up who faradj al sharpton did
the yo yo is from the month of May
help to whine same way to pay the
shot in friendly unequal filter it down
in a state will mix said she forced
or aegon jon art school in marie
intimate rooms two years but the good
thing i love italy rahmani
dark chocolate leather loses voices
Saturday at Bellelay said lamia late at night
there are
johan micoud the fingers the letters
were at Canada Day
levine tribal leader deceased sheikh
khalil same which muttahida then
moussa and mamba mavericks of the
gives fitch that he had to redouble and
treacherous joachim of age I fear
different matron sawyers at the marpa
form of a ballot signature
secrets the court of gerard stadium allard
moussa and tones the Nazis or from
barbaric be boilerwork to 1000 kwh
is morning wafou rich ly moba de
back after marriage proposal
el harrach with a smooth skull to say she
hurt me that we were taken
go for dinner or babylon ad de kabila son
masseube adage choukrane video the audio
nan she will draw from unrolled mathilde
the gym fun network six months total time
at the theater corona faso thomas soan mana
pools the line a life nan shan there the
Serbian has huge fruits the victim
old zealand the one nam dinh masao hara
collins put the early music hall list
of fame
namli tawfir done by hacavie madam there
flames
she shows eminem did not bring herself to
beat
ouattara to be a candidate
[Applause]
sk
two flats music before the king's
duplicate artists speech where gibson 6
August at which was somehow
so I was not wrong as a volunteer
for the young man
[Applause]
a given space the td ringers
[Music]
we
sum
[Music]
I am
Oh
you
[Music]
this world
I
keynes prelates the Belgian on us who we
[Music]
gentleman
no
[Music]
Gen.
and
what
I
hot
this year again
momo
I
[Music]
such
and
no
[Music]
it is
and
I
[Music]
tandja
I am
Yes
[Music]
all
jeans
Yes
probed
[Music]
[Applause]
and so you know buying a new one of
ten key words speech stories in
the tragic night
of 6 October 1996 rebels have
attacked our hospital at emirate the
Democratic Republic of Congo
more than 30 people killed patients
beat in the links at close range
staff can not flee killed
cold blood
I could not imagine that this
was only the beginnings forced to leave
the emirate in 1999 we created
the panzi hospital in bukavu where I
works today as I
obstetrician columns the first
admitted patient was a victim of
rape having been shot in his
genitals the macabre violence does not
knew no limit
this unfortunately born violence
never stopped one day like the others
the hospital made a call after the
wire a colleague in chlorinated weapons if he
please send us quickly a
ambience
please hurry up so we
sent an ambulance
as we usually do
two hours later the ambulance is
income inside a little girl from
just and 18 months she was bleeding
abundantly and was immediately brought
in the operating room when I'm
arrived the nurses while in tears the
infant bladder on the device
genital his rectum and is gravely
damaged by the penetration of a
adult
we pray in silence my god says all
that what we see is not true
tell us it's a bad dream says
my body waking up everything will be fine but this
was not a bad dream
it was the reality it is in front of our
new reality the republic
democratic of the congo
as for our baby arrived I
realized that these problems could not
not find a solution to the block
operative but that it was necessary to fight
against the root causes of these
atrocities
I went to the village of the cases you
to talk with men why
you do not protect your babies your
girls and your women where are the
authorities in these villages to my great
surprise the villager knew the
suspect
everyone was afraid of him because he
was a member of the provincial parliament and
I try to be absolute
on the population for several months
his militia terrorized the entire village he
had a style and fear huh you have a
human rights defender who had
had the courage to denounce the facts the
deputies escaped without consequence
his parliamentary immunity him
allowed to abuse with impunity
these two babies were followed by
dozens of other children raped when
the 48th victim arrived we were
desperate with other defenders of
human rights
we seized a military court
finally these young people were pursued
and judged as a crime against humanity
rape of bba vaults ceased
calls to panzi too but the future
sexual and reproductive psychology
reproductive of his babies is mortgaged
what happened to kavumu and who
continues today in many
other villages in the Congo such as
rapes and massacres to be blessed and
kasai was made possible by
the absence of a state of law
the foundation of traditional values
and the reign of impunity in particular
for the people in power
rape massacre torture
insecurity spreads the lack
of education create a spiral of
unprecedented violence
the human balance sheets of this perverse chaos
and organized
has been hundreds of thousands of
women raped more than 4 million
displaced persons within the
country and the loss of 6 million
visual
imagine the equivalent of all the poor
of the entire population of the brand
decimated the peacekeepers the
United nations experts have not been
spared then I found death in
fulfillment of their mandate
the mission of the united nations in
democratic republic of the congo remain
present until these days so that the
situation does not escalate further
we are grateful to them
however despite their efforts this
human tragedy it goes on without
all the leaders are
prosecuted
this the fight against impunity can
break the spiral of violence and we
have all
the power to change the course of
the story
when and why
we are fighting are just your majesty
your distinguished royal highness excellence
members of the Nobel Committee
dear madam nadia
ladies and gentlemen of peace
it is in the name of the Congolese people that
I accept the Nobel Peace Prize this is
asset
[Applause]
it is to all victims of violence
sexual intercourse around the world
what gede 10 is taken it's with
humility that I present to you
raising the voices of the victims of
sexual violence in conflict and
the hopes of my compatriots I
take this opportunity to thank
all those who during these years have
supported our fight I think in
particular to organizations
peasant institutions or to my
colleagues to my family and to my dear
wife madeleine
[Applause]
my name is dennis my home
I come from a richest country in the
planet
yet the people of my country are among
the world's poorest the reality
disturbing and that the abundance of our
natural resources gold cobalt coltan
and other and strategic minerals
feeds the source war of violence
extreme and abject poverty in
Democratic Republic of Congo
we all love beautiful cars
jewels gadgets
I myself have a smartphone these objects
contain minerals that are found
from us often extracted in
inhumane conditions by children
young people who are bullied
and sexual violence while driving
your electric car using
your smartphone admires your jewelry
think for a moment about the human cost
of making these objects as
that consumer the least that one
can do
as a consumer the least that
we can do
and insist that these products be
made with respect for dignity
human
close your eyes in front of the dramas
to be complicit it's not just
the perpetrators of the violence that are
responsible for their crimes
but also those who choose to
look away
my country is systematically looted
with the complicity of people who
pretend to be and our pillet leaders
for their power to loot for them
riches and their ticket fame to
the expense of millions of women and men
innocent children abandoned in a
extreme misery while profits
nominees ray ended up on
opaque accounts of an oligarchy
predatory 'it's been twenty years since
for day that at the panzi hospital I
see the consequences of this bad
governance of my country
db girl young woman mother grammar and
also men and boys violated of
cruel way often in public in
collective by inserting plastic
burning or introducing objects
blunt dallaire genitals
I told you about the details
the Congolese people
and humiliated abused slaughtered since
more than two decades in the light of
the international community today
today thanks to the news
information technologies and
communication
no one can say I did not know
not with these Nobel Peace Prizes
I call the world to witness and I
urge you to join us for
put an end to this suffering that makes
shame on our common humanity
the inhabitants of my country have
desperate for peace but
how to build peace on
mass graves
how to build peace without truth
nor reconciliation
how to build peace without justice
neither repair
at the moment I'm talking to you report is
the selfish mildew in the drawers of a
office in new york
it was written after an investigation
professional and rigorous on
war crimes and violations of
human rights perpetrated in the congo this
survey explicitly number of
victims of the places
dates but and authors struggle
it is report of the established mapping project
by the high commissioners of the nations
human rights not described
less than 617 war crimes and crimes
against humanity
and maybe even crimes of genocide
what is the world waiting for them to be
taken into account
there is no lasting peace without
justice
but justice is not negotiated earthly
the courage to take a critical look
impartial on the events that
have been raging for too long in the
Great Lakes Region
let's have the courage to reveal the names of
perpetrators of crimes against humanity
to simply avoid them
continue to mourn this region
martyrdom let us have the courage to recognize
our mistakes of the past
let's have the courage to tell the truth and
perform the work of the memoirs
dear Congolese compatriots let's have the
courage to take our destiny in hand
let's build peace
[Applause]
let's build peace let's build
the future of our country
together let's build a better future
for africa
nobody will do it for us
ladies and gentlemen of peace
the paintings that I brushed you
offered a sinister reality but
let me tell you
the story of sarah it was us
transferred to the panzi hospital in a
critical state his village had been
attacked by an armed group that had
massacred all his family leaving her
only taken hostage she was brought
in forest attached to a bare tree all
days sarah was suffering violence
collective
until she loses consciousness
b2c rape used as a weapon of war and
to destroy of course sarah but
also his family his community brief
simply destroy the tissues
on arrival at the hospital
sarah could not walk or even
hold up and could not hold back
nor her nice urine and that because of
the severity of his injuries
urinary genitals and digestive coupled with
an infection on added
no one could imagine that she
would one day be able to recover
on his feet
yet every day that passed
the desires to continue to live shine
in his eyes
every day that passes and it was she
who encouraged the nursing staff to
is not losing hope
every day that passes and sarah it's
was beating for his survival
today it's a beautiful woman
smiling strong charming sarah stood
committed to helping people and a lived
a story similar to his
it received 50 US dollars a
allowance that our house transits
dorcas grants women wishing to
rebuild their lives on the socio
economic
today sarah runs her little
business
she bought a small lot the
mozilla foundation ideas with tons
to make a roof she could get
to build a home
she is autonomous she is very proud
to be autonomous his story shows that
even if a situation is difficult and
seemed desperate the determination
with determination
there is always hope at the end of
tunnel
if a woman like sarah does not give up
who are we to do this and
of course the story says it stops
Congolese but there is sahara in
Central African Republic in Colombia in
bosnia at miyama in iraq and in well
other countries in conflict in the world
at panzi our care program
holistic that includes support
medical psychological social economic
and legal have tracked down even though the road
towards healing is long and difficult
he the victims have the potential to
transform their suffering into power
they can become actresses of
positive change in society
this is the case already the city of joy
our rehabilitation center in bukavu
where women are helped to spread
their destiny to hand however they do not
can not do it alone and our role
is to listen to them like today
we listen to madam nadia mourad at
nadia your courage your daring
your ability to restore hope
a source of inspiration for the world
whole but for me especially the
Nobel Peace Prize which is ours
awarded today will have no value
actual crate it can change
concretely the lives of the victims of
sexual violence
departure the world and helped bring back
peace in our countries
so what can we do
or what can you do
firstly it's our responsibility
everyone to act in this way and to act is
a choice is a choice to stop or not
violence against women from
to create or not a positive masculinity
that promotes gender equality in time
of peace as in times of war
[Applause]
to act is a choice to support or not
a woman to protect her or not from
defend launched right to fight or not
at his side in the countries ravaged by the
Conflicts
finally it's a choice to build
or not peace in the countries in conflict
to act is simply refused
indifference
if it is necessary to make war it is the
war against indifference that gnaws
our societies today
secondly we are all would be
vabs with these women and
their loved ones and we all have to
appropriating these commons including the
states that have to stop hosting
the leaders who tolerated or worse
use sexual violence to
access to power
states must
states must stop them
welcome with the red carpets
and then all states must trace
a red against the use of rape
as a weapon of war
a red line that would be synonymous with
political economic sanctions and
prosecution
to do an act is just not
difficult
to do a right act is not difficult
it's a question of political will
thirdly we must recognize
the sufferings of the survivors of
all violence against women
in armed conflicts and support them
holistically in their process
of healing
if I insist on repairs
these measures that gives them a
compensation and satisfaction l air
allow to start a new life
that's a human right I call them
states to support the initiative of the
creation of a global fund for
repairs for victims of
sexual violence in conflict
armed
[Applause]
fourthly on behalf of all
widows of all the heads of the orphans
massacres committed in the republic
democracy of the Congo and all
Congolese peace loving I call the
international community finally has
considered the project mapping reports
and his recommendations that the law be
said that's where it would allow the people
Congolese in crying his dead
to mourn forgive his executioners
overcome his suffering and projected himself
serenely in the futures eventually
after 20 years of bloodshed
frosts massive displacements of
populations the Congolese people
desperately waiting for the application of
the responsibility to protect
civilian populations
when their government can not or
do not want to do them
the people are waiting to explore the paths
a lasting peace
it's peace goes through the principle plug
transparent free elections
credible and peaceful
[Applause]
at work the Congolese people
let's build a state where the government is
serving its people
an emerging state of law capable of
to bring about sustainable development and
harmonious where only in republic
democratic of the congo
but in all Africa let's build a
state where all the political actions
economic and social issues are centered on
the human being and where the dignity of
citizens and restore your majesty
distinguished members of the Nobel Committee
ladies and gentlemen of peace
the challenges is clear and it's up to our
scope for
for the sahara for women the
men and children of the congo
I send you an urgent call from
not just to issue and the price
nobel of peace but to put you
stand up and say together aloud
violence in a democratic republic
of Congo
it's enough, it's too much peace
now
Thank you
dr mukwege
[Music]
on the trolley bus network that I
prove myself he specified
[Applause]
anne aphrodite and a press n is going
speechi of charlemont multi city of
prague world is big event in bella
the economy
[Applause]
[Music]
m
and
we
[Music]
and
e
yeah
[Music]
we
[Applause]
as for abdou fall took off to libya
the global peace prize money to take him
his home or stover
m
[Music]
[Applause]